no it's time for Quebec corner with your
oh yeah
and Johnny prob'ly spawns oh ok welcome
to take in that corner
my name is beyond book my name is Yogi
Trombley today we're gonna talk about
the healthcare in the States United
Obamacare and the single-payer system
and Quebec here it's been national easy
for a long time socialized health care
Obama say he want to move to single
payer that's what we call a cutaway hey
sound fancy we have the budget for that
anyway told father know he give us the
budget for projection oh how do they
know we do it again I know there that's
why I put it in there that's why I pay
you guy you all afraid cause of the
Carroll bomber okie in Quebec we have it
for a long time and work no problem ok
it worked perfect perfect that's it
example a-- tell them the story about
your shop one year ago I work on stick
show elongate and I'm walking and I step
on the come on convey so long that's my
I spiked oil it goes right through my
Fuji got Timberland a key right through
a Timberline car yes go right in it so I
go to doctor I need to get a tetanus
shot look and I take me but Ike for five
months and now you feel after that hey I
feel okay
everyone's in the wild of my jaw gets a
bit stuck that's how it's working Quebec
okay not like hospital you go United
States they send you barber gonna show
you hot you know I know may know me no
no speaking of barbers your hair it look
nice
another time I earth my back doing my
accepts is Jane Fonda yes good take that
Wow
dog best perfect I go to doctor I say my
back hurt I need to get a MRI
no that's not good they're like 10
machine in the old country they're gonna
send me to guess be easy look I know me
no me no me no I go back 16 month later
I got it no problem I have discount me
either
alright sometimes you walk a bit funny
but it fall asleep but you know may is
price you pay for nothing and that's it
cost nothing you want to ask is that
better than an ad look does like asking
if sale in is better than Mariah Carey
cocky but I have to get serious for a
moment because there's problem not
perfect to 2005 okay shall we
vs. Quebec the Supreme Court of the
Quebec you know this they say oh no is
no more is unconstitutional to make the
people wait for that long when they need
care we're gonna have to open it up to
privatization oh yeah that's the worst
okay they say yeah it's violation of the
right to man because the people they
wait long time you they die sometime I
tell you law the governor ma they don't
know they don't know meld they don't
know that's why they got a run you are
health care not some guy you want the
money in his pocket but you want to know
something that's cool okie Quebec now is
going more Praveena private okey but you
guys in the States United with Obamacare
you starting to come our way
that's cool though that's cool there
yeah maybe we get a chick-fil-a to death